et du côté de la situation sanitaire
selon les derniers chiffres de santé
publique france en dénombre près de
14000 nouvelles contaminations ou kobe
19 en 24 heures
soixante trois personnes sont décédées à
l'hôpital et 844 patients sont
actuellement en réanimation
le taux de positivité des tests se situe
lui à 7,1 6% alors que doit-on retenir
des annonces du ministre des solidarités
de la santé sur l'évolution de
l'épidémie soulève tels des
interrogations c'est notre décryptage en
compagnie de nos invités et pour en
parler nous ont rejoints frédéric
jeanjean secrétaire général de l'ump des
bouches du rhône c'est l'union des
métiers et des industries de
l'hôtellerie bonsoir à vous à vos côtés
jacques myard mer les républicains de
maisons laffitte bonsoir est avec nous
également ce soir en duplex violaine
guérin médecin endocrinologue bonsoir
alors justement pour commencer je vais
me tourner vers vous docteur violaine
guérin olivier ferrand le ministre de la
santé a parlé d'un virus qui circulent
trop vite dans les métropoles en même
temps un frémissement positif dans
d'autres métropoles
il faudra attendre lundi pour savoir où
pas si paru si paris bascule en alerte
maximale alors comment le comprendre
ça chauffe mais la situation reste sous
contrôle où finalement le pays prend du
retard et risquent une perte de contrôle
dans les semaines à venir
alors je suis un médecin en ville et je
voulais préciser que nous ne sommes pas
du tout en train d'observer cette
panique générale qui est annoncé il me
paraît extrêmement important que la
france très rapidement modifie ces
seuils d'amplification des tests pcr
comme l'a fait récemment parce que on
est dans des statistiques qui ne
correspondent pas du tout à ce que l'on
voit nous en ville alors on parle donc
de l'hôpital dont le miz récente et
parle d'un million de tests ils sont nés
il s'en est félicité ça ne suffit pas
alors c'est beaucoup trop de tests en
fait pour faire des tests simplement
chez les personnes symptomatique donc
aujourd'hui on fait du dépistage à tout
va avec des tests qui
ils comprennent beaucoup de tests faux
positifs et des patients asymptomatiques
etc
donc on n'est pas du tout dans une
logique médical correct aujourd'hui
d'évaluation de la situation sanitaire
nous nous les médecins de terrain nous
pouvons comparer à ce qui se passait en
février mars avril où effectivement on
voyait des patients tous les jours sous
franco vide etc
aujourd'hui ce n'est absolument pas la
réalité et on manipule beaucoup les
données il ya même des erreurs de
données puisque j'ai lu il ya quelques
heures un article montrant des erreurs
dans les saisies de santé publique
france a priori on a vu qu'à marseille
l' ars paca à donner des évaluations qui
se ne se sont pas avérées justes
donc il ya beaucoup de deux à la fois je
pense d'incompétence d'erreurs
et puis surtout la santé et manipulé
actuellement pour prendre des données et
des mesures qui sont extrêmement
liberticide qui ne se justifie pas
médicalement
alors qu'on a des traitements en phase
précoce qui existe on a certes des
problèmes de tension spital hier mais
qui ne correspondent pas à la réalité de
l'épidémie qui sont des tensions qui
sont liées à la destruction de notre
système de santé depuis des années on a
encore appris qu'on avait supprimé trois
mille cinq cents lits en 2019
ça c'est quelque chose qui se poursuit
depuis des années et quelque part moi je
suis presque un petit peu en colère par
rapport à aux médecins hospitaliers qui
certes ont manifesté fait des grèves etc
mais qui a réduit carrément arrêté de
travailler depuis un certain temps pour
que l'état français sauvent le système
de santé français et arrête alors
détruire donc aujourd'hui
alors on manque de lit on oui oui
docteur on va on va on va revenir à mais
peut-être qu'on va entendre les luttes
terrain jacques milliard sur ce que vous
venez d'entendre les propos du docteur
violaine guerra vous dont le rôle est
majeur
olivier verront l'a souligné ce soir
vous savez il est difficile pour un
maire d'évaluer correctement la pandémie
ce matin j'étais en conciliabule est en
négociation ou plus vigilants pour
parler avec un professeur de l'hôpital
foch in iz attendent aujourd'hui la
montée en puissance de la pandémie alors
qu'il y ait eu des erreurs du
gouvernement et de plusieurs
gouvernements dans le passé notamment
sur les crédits qui auraient dû être
allouée à l'hôpital et que la notion de
service public a été perdu de vue c'est
exact car on est absorbé la purge
budgétaire d'une vision totalement
libérale de bruxelles et on l'a payé
très cher donc il faut retrouver de ce
côté-là des priorités nationales et des
priorités d'investissement ça c'est
évident mais je pense néanmoins que
aujourd'hui on assiste à une montée en
puissance de la pandémie et il serait
vain de croire qu'on va y échapper non
madame je suis désolé vous avez un point
de vue sachez alors vous savez chez les
médecins il ya autant d'opinions de chez
les politiques on est d'accord
voilà mais il n'en demeure pas moins il
n'en demeure pas moins qu'il y à une
montée en puissance actuellement on le
voit sur les chiffres il ne faut pas
véritablement jouer avec ça et en tant
qu'élu c'est le principe de précaution
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle on
assiste sur les notions de se laver les
mains sur les notions de distance sur le
port du masque et je crois que je peux
que faire cela c'est à dire rappeler les
précautions
heureusement ça a des avantages c'est
que vous constatez vous médecin qui a
moins de gastro-entérite ou des choses
comme ça parce qu'on se touche moins les
uns les autres ou il ya un changement et
ça c'est important c'est que ce
gouvernement a compris qu'il y avait des
mères et qu' il les associe alors bien
n'y songez pas reçu d'appel devait en
je suis amer d'une commune de 24
habitants mais en tout cas cette volonté
de ce
appuyer davantage sur les élus locaux
aujourd'hui ce que reconnaît le
gouvernement
c'est une bonne méthode visiblement la
pentecôte est descendu sur la tête des
gouvernants et ils se sont aperçus qu'il
y avait des mères équipe allait
peut-être les associés maintenant savoir
si tout ce qui est fait et tout ce qui
est fait est la vérité ça c'est autre
chose comme ça au résultat mais ce qui
est certain c'est que en tant que maire
agents de l'état il est tout à fait
légitime que il est même urgent que le
gouvernement s'adresse à nous parce que
quand on voit ce qui s'est passé à
marseille où ces tombes est elle une
case de jupiter ça c'est pas admissible
et il est évident que nos amis
restaurateurs ils ont raison d'une
journée même si ensuite il faut pas
gamelin et bien justement frédéric
jeanjean depuis marseille est également
avec nous je le rappelle vous êtes
secrétaire général de l'union des
métiers et des industries de
l'hôtellerie
le gouvernement parle d'une embellie 1 à
marseille olivier verront va
s'entretenir demain avec les élus locaux
l'ouverture des cafés restaurants sans
doute au menu je vous propose d'écouter
au lit et veyran vous réagissez ensuite
frédéric jeanjean
le gouvernement va dans les prochains
jours examiner les propositions qui lui
sont faites c'est normal par les
représentants du secteur de la
restauration et étudier des règles
éventuels qui pourraient permettre aux
restaurants y compris en zone d' alerte
maximale de rester en tout ou partie
ouvert mais avec des règles sanitaires
renforcés pour permettre de limiter au
maximum les risques de contamination ces
nouvelles règles si elle nous tout
semble si elle nous semble suffisamment
robustes protectrice contrôlable seront
alors soumises au haut conseil de santé
publique
et si elle était validée elle pourrait
alors s'appliquer dans tous les
territoires en zone d' alerte maximale
alors frédéric jeanjean caisse quand
vous réagissez à ses propos d'olivier
ferrand est ce que vous espérez un
changement de traitement dès demain tout
d'abord gérer quel gâchis quel gâchis
quand monsieur vers ans est descendu à
marseille la semaine dernière
nous avons demandé à le rencontrer
justement pour lui proposer ces mesures
il a fallu une semaine de mobilisation
il a fallu pousser toute une filière les
cafetiers les restaurateurs et les
fournisseurs à bout pour qu en fait il
se décide à écouter ce que nous pouvons
proposer
je trouve ça assez fort de café
parce que nous arrivons nous avons des
propositions à faire
nous connaissons nos métiers et nous
savons ce que nous pouvons avancer
et là tout d'un coup effectivement
monsieur venir parler de la pentecôte
mais je dirais mais c'est même mieux que
ça
les sourds entendent et les aveugles se
met à voir alors figurez-vous que venant
à marseille fait demain à marseille
nous avons une grande manifestation eh
bien monsieur vers ans a trouvé opportun
de nous consulter de mer en fin de
matinée parce que il s'est rendu compte
que outre les statistiques
outre une situation que nous connaissons
tous
parce que les professionnels que nous
sommes nous entendons nous voyons dans
nos proches nos familles nos clients
chez nos salariés que cette maladie pose
un problème
nous ne sommes pas inconscient nous
voulons trouver des solutions parce
qu'il faut quand même que nous puissions
vivre malgré ce virus trouver des
solutions et j'irai même plus loin
comment se fait-il que alors qu'on est
confronté cette pandémie
on voit dans les transports en commun
les choses absolument effarante et qu'on
voit ça dans toutes les métropoles et
que derrière ça dans les centres
commerciaux dans les grandes surfaces on
voit les choses tout aussi aberrante
eh bien nous les cafetiers et les
restaurateurs
nous nous refusons et surtout le pays
maintenant à servir de variable
d'ajustement pour la communication d'un
gouvernement qui ne sait pas où il va
alors s'il veut trouver une direction
qu'il se tourne vers les locaux qui se
tournent vers les acteurs de terrain
vers les représentants des métiers que
nous que nous sommes nous nous pouvons
avancer des propositions des solutions
nous ne sommes pas des scientifiques
que c'est pas nous qui tirons aussi le
sont bonnes ou mauvaises mais nous avons
l'exemple de l'italie à côté de chez
nous où se rend compte que l'épidémie
fait moins de ravages
parce qu'il jouit des protocoles à
renforcer alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
perdu tout ce temps là pourquoi est ce
que nous nous avons perdu une semaine où
ne manquent pas pu travailler ou n'ont
pas pu créer de la richesse et cette
richesse est le sert justement à bombay
sur l'ensemble du territoire pour aider
les soignants pour aider les gens qui
sont malades pour aider les gens qui
sont en difficulté c'est ce gâchis qui
nous rend pauvre de nous violaine des
violences graves
vous qui êtes mettre ça en tant que
médecin est ce que cette toute cette
fermeture des bars et des restaurants
même dans une métropole où le virus
circule fort activement est ce qu'elle
aurait pu être évité avec davantage de
mesures selon vous et lesquels bien sûr
que ça devrait être évitée puisque c'est
totalement incohérent et comme le
monsieur le signale quand on voit ce qui
se passe dans le métro à paris par
exemple tous les matins ces mesures sont
totalement incohérente je rappelle au
maire de maisons laffitte que
l'indicateur de surveillance de cette
pandémie
ce sont les décès et aujourd'hui tout
est manipulé avec les tests avoir un
test positif ne veut pas forcément dire
que la personne est malade ne veut même
pas forcément dire que le virus est
vivant chez cette personne si on a
trouvé du matériel génétique etc
donc si vous regardez la courbe des
décès aujourd'hui on est exactement dans
une courbe annuel classique
il faut se souvenir qu'on a selon les
jours entre 1500 et 1700 décès par jour
en france et quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui le nombre de décès annoncé
par qu'ovide et qui ne sont pas tous en
plus d'aider des annonces de décès avec
des décos vite comme coach primitive
on n'est pas du tout dans une
problématique de pandémie est en ce
moment donc toutes les mesures sont
prises sont très irrationnel et là on
heureusement que les restaurateurs bouge
il faut bouger parce que ce qui se passe
est tout à fait anormal et ça va être
c'est la mort des dpm de beaucoup de pme
etc
et c'est absolument injustifié sur le
plan médical
alors jacques myard ça c'est très
important mais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
il ya eu un référé parce que les gens du
monde du sport ont déposé un référé à
rennes s'est il entendu par la justice
et il faut absolument que les
restaurateurs fassent pareil il faut pas
lâcher le terrain ce n'est pas justifiée
médicalement aujourd'hui alors oui en
février mars avril
il fallait prendre des mesures
jacqueline jacques myard on entend le
manque de confiance chez violaine guérin
mais aussi c'est frédéric jeanjean par
rapport au gouvernement ce manque de
confiance bruno retailleau sénateur de
votre famille politique ce manque de
confiance envers le gouvernement il a
souligné à 1 ce matin dans une interview
du coup est ce que le gouvernement
finalement craint aujourd'hui que la
population ne veulent plus accepter ces
mesures alors écoutez ce qui ce qui est
évident c'est qu'il y a confiance
vis-à-vis du gouvernement et a ajouté à
d'autres crij la paire de la justice par
exemple la querelle avec les magistrats
est quelque chose d'assez grave même
peut-être encore plus grave à terme sur
la stabilité du pays
ce qui est bien à jour sur un point
précis c'est que effectivement je le
souhaite d'ailleurs les courbes des
décès ne demande pas mais parce qu on
est plus efficace souvent dans le
traitement de la maladie antérieure on
après des problèmes de ce côté là donc
ce n'est pas vraiment un indicateur nous
en tant qu'élu madame nous sommes
obligés de prendre en compte un certain
nombre de mesures mais il y à un
cohérence et là je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec mes deux interlocuteurs à
savoir qu' on nous donne notamment des
protocoles dans les écoles qui sont de
plus en plus laxiste et hongrois
deuxièmement il
j'ai pris tout à l'heure encore le rer à
paris on peut pas dire que il y avait un
établissement des mesures de
distanciation les uns avec les autres
donc c'est là où c'est incohérent et je
suis con
un cul que appliquée au restaurant une
fermeture à 1h pourquoi cette heure et
dès lors que nos amis restaurateurs
prennent des mesures de dénonciation ça
peut fonctionner mais ce qui s'est passé
à marseille
chers amis marseillais tu sais qu'à un
moment il ya eu véritablement au moment
d'une victoire de foot
un mélange tout azimut et vous payez un
peu en sac si ça a été vu quand même c
était des embrassades assez singulière
bon ce qui est clair c'est qu'on est
face à une pandémie que aujourd'hui elle
s'accélère parce que bien sûr on peut
critiquer le gouvernement
moi je râlais on en attendait faut être
un peu sérieux que cardiff s'est combiné
qu'une grande partie une grande partie
de l'espagne s'est continuée que les
israéliens se sont comptines et donc je
suis en opposant au gouvernement et à
monsieur mâcon depuis toujours mais je
ne vais pas accuser le gouvernement en
disant faites attention et elle le
premier ministe d'ailleurs et biron tout
à l'heure n'a rien dit de plus il a
simplement dit on se concerte avec les
maires mais on est là pour faire
attention
donc on voit très bien qu'aujourd'hui
naviguait alors d'accord alors je vous
propose via le chef de l'état emmanuel
macron oui je vous donne la parole tout
de suite après frédéric jeanjean mais je
vous propose avant d'écouter emmanuel
macron lui aussi s'est exprimé ce matin
sur la pandémie on écoute il faut
partout on ne peut relancer relance est
relancé et dès maintenant il faut pas
attendre que tout soit simple que tout
soit clair que tout soit sûr et
transparent parce que moi je ne sais pas
vous dire la date de fin du virus
impossible et les gens qui d'ailleurs en
face tu peux vous dire on aura un vaccin
au mois de mars prochain et d'avril très
sincèrement vous trompe on va sans doute
durablement vivre avec le virus et donc
il faudra expliquer des dispositifs de
freinage autre met donc à chaque fois
qu'on le peut on doit foncer avancé
croire diversifié investir alors
frédéric jeanjean quelle est votre
réaction après ses propos du chef de
l'état on doit foncer on doit investir
il a même appelé les chefs d'entreprise
à ne pas douter qu est-ce que vous
il répondait aujourd'hui écoutés quand
j'entends monsieur virant dire que on
pourra manger assis mais pas boire à s'y
est essayé d'ouvrir un front entre les
cafetiers et les restaurateurs
je trouve ça assez cocasse et si je peux
donner un conseil au chef de l'état
c'est quand il prend la parole et qu'il
est temps doux et qu'il met un masque et
que les gens qui sont autour de lui met
un masque parce que nous c'est ce que
nous faisons quotidien dans nos
établissements
alors voilà ça c'est la première chose
ne pas douter
mais attendez pour créer la confiance il
faut des conditions et quelles sont les
conditions ce moment on navigue à vue
aussi par moments et en plus on nous
méprise
alors là à bout d'un moment je vous dire
ça commence à devenir un exercice
compliqué parce que nous demandons à
rencontrer le ministre qui ne répondent
même pas notre demande on est obligés de
mobiliser tous azimuts et derrière ça il
est obligé de revenir de faire machine
arrière
vous savez nous en sommes dans les
bouches du rhône vous avez tous eu deux
filières vous avez les restaurateurs les
cafetiers les hôteliers les discothèques
il faut pas les oublier
ça fait sept mois qu'ils ont fermé sept
mois lavez les fruits culture qui est de
nous rejouer à 40 ans en tant qu'élu
local en tant qu'élu local technique
vous arrivez à faire le lien justement
cette colère j'imagine que vous
l'entendez aussi chez vos administrés
vous arrivez à la faire remonter ou pas
au gouvernement comment ça se passe dans
la communication et dans les yvelines
puisque nous avons cette chance nous ne
sommes pas astreints autant de
contraintes et de couvre-feu que à
marseille à excès et loire à paris et
donc de ce côté là on a plus de latitude
mais moi je suis parfaitement d'accord
avec ce qui vient dire par notre ami
marseillais à savoir qu'il ya une
incohérence l'aiba vous avez fait passer
les propos de vers en est ensuite les
propos du chef de l'état je suis désolé
il n'y a aucune cohérence
parce que d'un côté on vous dit il peut
investir on est bien d'accord
j'ai toujours pensé qu'il manque d
investissement en france notamment dans
les hôpitaux comme partout ailleurs
mais ce qui est clair c'est que c'est
incohérent il ya deux discours qui sont
antinomiques dont un qui dit attention
attention c'est le tocsin et l'autre qui
est libre on lui apprend à vivre avec
mais il faut travailler et il faut que
tout que l'économie tourne c'est vrai
aussi parce que la vraie catastrophe qui
risque de nous arriver avec neuf cent
mille chômeurs de plus c'est un problème
économique donc sociologique donc
sociale et avec des gens qui sont
aujourd'hui dans l'impasse
donc c'est là où il y a le problème mais
il faut je dirais adapter les règles
n'ont pas de confinement mais les règles
de distanciation de façon à ce que
l'économie puisse reprendre et que l'on
est qu'on puisse mais agir avec la
précaution nécessaire mais il est je
suis d'accord une fois avec le chef de
l'état
il va falloir vivre avec pendant encore
un bout de temps alors on va devoir
clore cet échange néanmoins violaine
guérin le mot de la fin
le mot de la fin c'est des traitements
existent en phase précoce moi je
conseille aux gens d'arrêter d'aller se
faire tester sinon aucun symptôme
parce que ils donnent ils cautionnent un
petit peu quelque part toute cette
panique que si les gens sont malades et
bien qu'ils aillent consulter leur
médecin généraliste comme on le fait
d'habitude cette pandémie
première épidémie est terminée
aujourd'hui il est possible qu'au mois
d'octobre novembre
enfin fin octobre début novembre
décembre on est une deuxième phase
puisque ce virus finalement c'est ce
qu'il a fait le sar skov un qui est
classé dans la même classe que le sascoc
2 il ya eu pendant deux ans des des
formes cliniques mais qui peut en plus
se sont estompées sont devenus de moins
en moins grave tout simplement grâce aux
mutations donc bien sûr il faut rester
prudent mais il faut pas empêcher le
pays de fonctionner parce qu'il ya
beaucoup plus de deux choses graves qui
sont en train de se passer avec nous on
voit des augmentations de suicides
tentatives de suicides de dépressions on
voit des dépôts de bilan dans les
entreprises du chômage et il faut
simplement vivre normalement
de tout temps il ya eu des bactéries des
virus qui se sont baladés il ya eu des
grippes il ya plein de choses là on a
rappelé aux gens aussi des règles
d'hygiène fondamentale donc ça ça n'a
pas fait de mal mais reprenons un schéma
de cette année en revanche il faut que
les français il faut que les français se
bougent pour sauver leur système de
santé
c'est ce qui me paraît important parce
que c'est ça aussi qu'on est en train de
payer
merci beaucoup violaine guérin d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin endocrinologue merci
avoue frédéric jeanjean secrétaire
général de l'union des métiers et des
industries de l'hôtellerie dans les
bouches-du-rhône merci à vous également
jacques myard mer les républicains de
maisons laffitte